Super villains
sad souls in costumes wanting you to think
they're all dark and deep what's it like
living life as a punchline but all it would
take would be one blessed act of rebellion
for you to restore your dignity in its entirety
you know the deal complete the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
you fail to follow my orders
in any way and i detonate the
explosive device in the base of your skull
love him or hate 'em these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few days
any questions and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so oh for god's sake
nothing like a bloodbath to start the day
they call you peacemaker
i cherish peace with all my heart
i don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it i
thought you were a crazy one. I am.
here's the deal we fail the mission you
died we find out any information you give
us is false you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates you die what no
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
suicide squad trailer video even though it's april
fool's day they dropped a brand new trailer with
a whole bunch of different footage a whole bunch
of new easter eggs and more of the team so if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos the other real big news
also not an april fool's day joke is that dc
cancelled a couple of the movies that were in
development so i'll explain that at the end of the
video too because the movies that they canceled
weren't really related to suicide squad stuff
there weren't going to be big crossovers with this
franchise the funny thing too is when james gunn
posted this he actually said that i always hate it
when they post a green band version of the trailer
as the exact same trailer so that's why he asked
them to put all different footage in this and he
did make a bit of an april fool's day joke he said
you know even though it is april fool's day the
only joke are these characters just sort of hyping
up the idea that the reason why he's using such
obscure characters such weird characters for this
team is because it goes with the entire idea that
they're meant to be the most expendable people
in the dc universe that amanda waller could find
like no one will care if you die no one will come
to your funeral so if you do it's no big deal i'll
just find other more obscure villains put them
on this team to deal with this problem that we
can't get the real heroes to deal with i do love
the idea that they're using starro for the main
villain and he was the classic original justice
league team-up villain but the justice league in
the dc eu for some reason is too busy to come
deal with starro this time the scene that they
open on with them opening the back of the plane
getting ready to jump out is very reminiscent of
the same scene of the justice league characters
getting ready to jump out of the back of batman's
carrier the big final fight in the justice league
snyder cut just to highlight the fact that we're
going from the a-list superheroes in the dc
universe to the d e and f list superheroes
like not even obscure enough to be c-list i do
love harley quinn's jacket though it says live
fast die clown which is another joker reference
there's another joker reference in peter capaldi's
voiceover dialogue where if you had a hard time
understanding him through his accent most british
people are like what are you talking about i can
totally understand what he's saying they didn't
have captions on the official version of the
trailer yet so what he's saying is super villains
sad souls and costumes wanting you to think
they're all dark and deep what's it like living
your life is a punchline you have to imagine he's
talking to them in a different scene they're just
mixing and matching this voiceover dialogue with
this separate footage but the funny thing about
him referring to the characters as punch lines
themselves is that they just introduced a new
character in dc comics called punchline and she's
joker's new assistant that replaced harley quinn
they have like their own rivalry between them
harley quinn versus punchline but i thought it was
a nice coincidence the way they mixed and matched
this footage of him joking about them being punch
lines with harley quinn in her relationship with
the joker then he says all it would take would
be one act of rebellion to restore all of your
dignity so i'm guessing he's trying to taunt
the suicide squad members into rebelling against
amanda waller which inadvertently even if they're
not really thinking about it would get them killed
because of the bombs and planted in their heads
and they literally juxtaposed that dialogue
right after this with amanda waller's speech
basically giving them the rules of the
suicide squad you complete the mission
you get 10 years knocked off your sentence at
bell rev prison and if you go rogue i detonate
the bomb in your skull like she even opens up the
briefcase with all the buttons that she can click
some of this footage is from the last trailer so
i'll try to focus mostly on the brand new scenes
but a lot of the repeated footage is of them
going up against starro there's some brand new
footage of this beach assault it seems like it's
going to be one of the biggest action scenes of
the movie but hard to tell when it happens during
the actual film there's a bunch of new king shark
footage this scene of him just looking inside
this fish tank and all these aquatic creatures
these also seem like alien creatures as well like
this doesn't seem like anything you would find on
planet earth and there are a lot of cosmic
things that are happening during the movie
because we have mon gal who's a cosmic character
from the superman comics and obviously starro is
an intergalactic villain we get some brand new
footage introducing some of the more obscure
members of the team like this is ratcatcher 2.
inside her cell there's a picture of her with
what seems like her father who was probably the
original version of ratcatcher within the dc eu
but they use these scenes to sort of show you
how she uses her powers to command all these rats
they also use her character to react to a lot of
the crazier members of the team like john cena's
peacemaker character or polka dot man we get a
slightly longer version of the john ostrander
cameo scene if you're not familiar with him he
is the original creator of the suicide squad in
the comics so they gave him a stan lee style
cameo during the film he's the person or the
doctor who's implanting all the bombs in their
heads james gunn said he did that on purpose
like who better to do this than the creator of
the suicide squad love the scene of them going
to pick up king shark in his cell and he's trying
to read the book but he's reading it upside down
he's trying so hard he's like a giant puppy dog
or something like that the way they're using him
is actually very similar to the animated version
of king shark on that harley quinn tv show if you
have been watching the animated show it's more of
an r-rated comedic spin on the batman comic book
characters so it seems like they're using him
the same way in this movie as they used him on
that series just a big dumb animal just trying to
do his best this briefcase scene is also a clever
way of giving you another look at the roster just
identifying the characters just because they are
so obscure people like wait a minute now who
are these people again i have a feeling they're
going to be a lot of promos like this over the
next couple of months where they keep repeating
the characters names on screen when they appear
in the trailers just to remind you who they are
most of you will probably notice though there's
a lot of characters from the first suicide squad
film the funny thing is if you actually look at
the official description and the breakdowns of
the movie that the studio is given the way they
talk about it this is the second version of the
suicide squad and the version from the first movie
is meant to be the very first version ever in the
dc universe like amanda waller's first attempt
at putting a suicide squad together even though
the suicide squad team in the comics goes back to
the 1980s so the way they described this version
of the team is that it was a reformed version of
the suicide squad that amanda waller puts together
with new members adding to the ranks of people
who didn't get killed off or get released from
prison or escape to go down and raid a nazi base
in corto maltese the trailers haven't conveyed too
much of what the actual story is in corto maltese
just that they go there and they also have to deal
with starro and this other foreign dictator
who seems like he's in control of the area
or maybe he's just a proxy for starro because the
way they reveal star on the trailer like he just
bursts up from that nazi base it seems like maybe
he'd been hiding there for years so it'll be funny
to see the way they weave starro like this giant
version of starro into the history of the dceu as
far as we know it and all the films that we've
seen so far like earlier in the timeline was
starro hiding out here manipulating people while
the events of wonder woman 1984 were playing out
during the actual 1980s in what is the connection
between starro and the nazis if this is a former
nazi base we get more captain boomerang scenes
i wasn't really a huge fan of what they did with
the character in the first suicide squad film
so it sounds like they're having a little bit
more fun with him this time around they also
confirm by nathan philly in theory he's called
tdk but that's not a name from the comics but it
sounds like it might stand for the detachable kid
because you literally see him detach his arms
from his body they give you more footage with the
weasel character he's being played by sean gunn as
an emotion capture role so it's sort of them doing
the same thing they do with him in rocket in the
marvel universe the guardians of the galaxy films
like avengers infinity war avengers end game most
of you know sean gunn plays craglin he's actually
going to come back during thor 4 love and thunder
we've actually seen pictures of him on set he's
got yondu's finn now after the events of avengers
end game and guardians of the galaxy vol 2. but
while they're filming scenes with rocket he also
does the motion capture for rocket because bradley
cooper does the voice but he just comes in later
after they filmed the footage to do the voice
over dialogue the funny thing that james gunn said
about his character too because people were asking
him on twitter why is king shark wearing pants and
he's a shark but weasel isn't wearing any clothes
and james gunn response was have you ever
tried to put clothes on your cat before i'm
also curious to see how they explained the mon
gal character and her presence here like why is
she being held captive in a prison is it because
her father mongol from the superman comics doesn't
care about her who captured her did superman
capture her because she is a superman villain
they show you a little bit of her abilities
during the trailer like she has enhanced
strength and durability like she jumps up on
that helicopter and takes it down just by herself
in the way they're pitching this too like this
is meant to be the full roster for task force x
the suicide squad notice that you don't see peter
capaldi's thinker here so it seems like at least
part of their mission has something to do with
his character and then it spirals up into the big
starro plot i have a feeling that it starts out
as one thing and then turns into the star oh plot
like the mission that amanda walla recruits them
for is not starro it's something else happening
in corto maltese and then it turns into the big
starro plot and if you notice the thinker poster
for peter capaldi's character they released has
starros all over it so it's just implying that
he has some connection to the starro character
that they haven't revealed in these trailers yet
like either he's trying to double cross them
and he's working with starro or they're just
trying to use him to help counteract the effects
of staro's psychic abilities so that they don't
all get mind controlled a lot of this footage of
them running around in plain clothes like their
street clothes reminds me of pulp fiction too like
they all have their full-blown comic book costumes
that you see them in most of the trailer but then
in some of this footage they're walking around in
their street clothes but you see all this footage
of them parting together one night maybe there's
some attack that happens while they're out of
costume in their playing clothes so they have
to roll in and they don't have time to put their
costumes back on they show you a little how polka
dot man's powers work all the polka dots all over
him can be turned into other things so some of
them can be turned into bombs some of them can
be turned into projectiles so this was happening
when he's throwing them at these people here the
different colors turn into different weapons and
i love the way john cena's character goes out with
his dialogue too like i love peace so much i don't
care how many people i have to kill to get it but
if you spotted any other new easter eggs in the
trailer footage here that i didn't mention during
the video just write them below in the comments
most of the other stuff i already covered in my
last big trailer video so i'll link that at the
end of this because it's all different footage but
just to explain the big announcement today about
the dc movies that warner brothers just cancelled
it's actually the new gods movie that eva duvernay
was doing with tom king and the aquaman spin-off
movie about the trench so it's actually not that
big a deal the trades like variety hollywood
reporter deadline that are reporting the news
say the new gods movie was cancelled because
they didn't want a movie featuring darkseid
so soon after seeing the version of dark side
in the justice league snyder cut like for
whatever reason they felt like it was too soon
to show you a different iteration of dark side
the funny thing about that is that we just got
done seeing multiple versions of the joker and
we're probably going to see another version of the
joker in the matt reeves batman trilogy at some
point in the next couple of years the whole thing
with them cancelling the aquaman spin-off about
the trench the response from the studio was they
felt like aquaman 2 was all the aquaman stuff that
they needed going on in the future until we get to
the next justice league film so i'm not too broken
up about the trench news or the new gods news i'm
sure we'll see future versions of darkseid once
they spin up in more cosmic dc films my next big
video will be my falcon and winter soldier episode
3 video that'll post friday then after that i'll
post my godzilla versus kong breakdown video on
easter eggs there's also a brand new space jam
trailer that's gonna be dropping this weekend so
i'll try to do a video for that too if i have
time while you wait for everything click here
for my godzilla versus kong ending and then credit
scene video and click here for that other suicide
squad trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!